From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Can you mention everybody here?
Yes, everyone knows.
It's a good idea to do this.
No, it's no more John Bishop.
Okay.
And I need a hand.
All right.
We're rolling.
It is Monday, May 13th, 2013.
We are in the home of William F. Russell here with us.
Esquire.
Doing an interview for the National Museum of African American History and Culture.
My name is Taylor Branch.
Bill Russell, the videographer, is John Bishop, assisted by Noah Bishop.
And from the museum, we have Elaine Nichols.
And we have Mr. Russell's longtime assistant and friend Anita Diaz.
And we are here to record an interview for posterity in this museum about Mr. Russell's life and views.
And this is the most formal part of this interview.
And we hope to just have a good time talking about the career of a legendary figure in American sports and American life.
Did you say, it's posterior?
Posteria.
All right.
So we're all in the next.
So let me ask you the first question.
Where do you remember getting the extraordinary laugh, which is one of the first things that people ask me about when they say that I, when they find out that I know you, is where did his laugh come from?
My mother, she told me never to hold back all this.
If I have to sneeze, sneeze.
If you have to laugh, laugh. Don't hold it back.
She says, good for your health.
Oh, that's good.
Well, you followed that advice.
When we were working years ago, we, Bill and I have a history of doing a book together about his life.
I talked an awful lot about your mother.
She died long before then.
I never met her.
But I didn't know your father, Mr. Charlie.
And it seemed to me in discussing and getting to know you that an awful lot of your character comes from those family people.
I think the first thing, the most memorable line you ever spoke to me was that you thought your character was formed by the fact that you never had a doubt that both of your parents loved you.
Is that correct?
That's the first thing I can remember as a person.
Is that, you know, or you, a baby, then the world opens up to you.
Well, I always had the confidence that my mother followed up with me.
And what they taught me was, is that if they loved me, I must be okay.
So if other people encounter me and they have a problem with me, my father said, that's their little red wagon.
And so, I never worked to be liked.
Because there would be hypocritical to me.
If I wanted to do things to make somebody like me, what is it worth?
A little background you grew up in Louisiana, born in 1934 in Monroe, Louisiana.
The second son of Katie and Mr. Charlie Russell.
The other figure that we talked about a lot in your childhood was your grandfather.
Well, both your grandfathers, but primarily grandfather Russell, you call the old man.
He was an extraordinary, one time in Louisiana, the night of the Clucos Claire.
The Clucos Claire had this black guy on the woods beating him.
And you could hear him screaming and crying for mercy.
At least a bottle away.
So my grandfather heard that.
He went and got his shotgun and loaded it with bird seeds.
And he went out and shot it to the crowd about a half a dozen times.
And it dispersed the crowd.
And he never went and seemed to get it just left.
And he saw my old duck, something others.
So he's picking up bird seeds for a week.
And when my father was born, my grandfather realized
that there was no school for the black children.
So he decided he got to talk to the other guys.
And they got together enough money.
And they went to the Zobby yard and bought some lumber.
And they bargained and negotiated.
He got to pay for the lumber.
And we got the wagons and the mules to take the lumber to the site.
They were building a schoolhouse.
So when they got back to the lumber yard,
they picked up the lumber.
The guy, let me ask them, what you boys going to do with all this lumber?
Well, one of them did the crowd said, we're going to build a schoolhouse for the kids.
He said, they don't need to know how to read the pick cotton.
In fact, I'm not going to let you do it, I'm not going to let you do a thing like that.
I'm not going to let you do a lumber.
So our grandfather said, okay, we're just going to give my money back.
He said, no, I'm not going to do that either.
There's no agreement that a white man has to respect
what about you black boys?
So my grandfather said, oh, let me get to the straight.
You're not going to give us a lumber.
And you're not going to give us a money back.
Well, the third option is I'll have to kill you.
And when they get a shotgun,
they kind of remember, I said, well, you know,
you guys have that lumber.
And so they built the schoolhouse.
And they got together $53 to hire a teacher for a year.
So they teach at the school that this built.
And that's the kind of stuff where he says, you know,
he says you're taking that top of nobody.
And a little bit of light.
My grandfather never spent much school on one single day.
My father went to the sixth grade that he dropped out.
I did four years of University of San Francisco.
And my younger's child, my daughter graduated from Harvard Law School.
So that's the evolution of the family for my grandfather,
to my kids from low school to Harvard Law School.
But at the time you were born in 1934, your mother already,
even though your father had practically no schooling
and your grandfather had none, she admired it.
She valued education so much, she named your little name as Felton,
after the president of, I think, Southern University of San Francisco.
His name was Felton Clark.
And so she gave me Felton to, similar path
that I was thinking about going to college.
In fact, my mother died of kidney failure.
And she was in hospital sick and she knew she was dying.
So she called my father and said, I want you to promise me something.
That you'll send my boys to college.
And my father said he promised you.
So when she died, we took her to Louisiana to be buried.
And while I was there, she had five sisters.
And they were debating who's going to take me, who's going to take my brother.
And he says, that debate is no bad.
I'm going to take them back to California and raise them myself.
They said, no, Mac can raise the kids.
He says, I promise my mother I will try.
So he sold his business and went to work in a foundry
for less a week than had been making a day.
And the reason he did that is because he wanted to be at the time at home.
Yes, he had to be home every night.
He says, you can't let kids raise themselves.
And I understood that.
And I appreciated that.
I just, well, I loved him.
He was like a 75th birthday.
And we were talking and I said, you know, I love you.
He says, well, I love you too.
That was the first time I'd ever said that.
But I knew it.
I think you said at one time that when he took you and your brother back to Oklahoma.
You went back on the train, right?
From your mother's funeral, this is in 1946.
You're 12.
It's very, very unusual that a single father, a widow,
would raise his two boys.
And he said, he talked, I think you said he talked to you the whole way back
about how you were going to live without your mother.
And he said, you had a tremendous loss.
But you got to live the way she wanted you to live.
And she was you be educated.
And I don't know much about it, but I'll help you with whatever I can.
And he said you're going to cook and clean.
Well, we had a set up where I cooked my brother wasch editions.
And then the next week he cooked and I'd wash dishes.
And there was no gourmet cook to that house.
I think I remember even earlier at one point you said that down in Louisiana,
you were going to come home from work.
Sometimes in the whole family would go out to play and he would carry all of you?
Yes, well, he was a big straw guy, okay?
Six, three, two, a hundred, twenty pounds.
And we had this huge field with tall grass like a red-and-futtle house.
And we'd go play hide and seek a new tall grass.
When they get to our starting point,
they'll go one arm, be on the other arm, and my brother was back,
and went full speed across that field.
And I thought he was so such a superman.
Yeah, I remember.
He was a lot of things that he'd always,
when I was playing with Celtics,
at all.
I was up in the cutchers in the Catskills.
And I was back and I was talking.
And one of the waiters came and said,
you hear what happened to Wilt?
I said, no, you get a car wreck or something,
but he said, dry fast.
And he says, no, he just signed a contract for $100,000 a year.
That's the first time any NBA player had reached that plateau.
In fact, I think Mickey Mantle,
or Jodie Margeo,
and I think really nice,
with all the four athletes making $100,000.
So I said to Red, well, I know what I want.
He just wants that.
I said, $100,000 and $1.
Because I just want to be peeing this league.
Okay?
So he said,
okay.
So I go back to my room, I call my father up,
and I said, Dad, you won't believe this.
They're going to pay me $100,000 a year to do this.
Tell you the reason I called you, tell you now,
you don't have to work anymore.
I'll make enough that I can think you're in the rest of the way.
He says, I don't want your damn money.
I got my own money.
I said, but that job you got's terrible.
He's working in a factory.
He says, listen.
I give these people $35 of the best years of my life.
Now, I'm going to give them a few of the bad ones.
That's exactly what he used to turn around.
I'd like to back up just a little bit for when you left one,
Role Louisiana, because as I understand it at any rate,
your family was part of what we now understand as the Great Migration,
or at least the World War II Migration.
A friend of mine wrote a book about it,
Isabelle Wilkerson, the wife of other sons.
I've met him maybe.
He's a wonderful writer.
Anyway, before your mother's funeral,
he left Louisiana and migrated first to Detroit,
and then out to Oakland.
Could you tell us exactly how that happened and why it happened?
Well, he first, he's working in his back factory.
And the S4 race.
And the boss says, can't give you a race, Charlie.
If I give you a race, you'd be making as much as some of the white bullets.
And I can't pay more U.S. as much as I pay the white guys.
And he used the inward to my father.
Just like it was nothing.
And so my father was at home that night.
And he was talking out loud.
And he says, you know, I'm going to have to leave here.
Of course, if I stay here, who will raise my kids?
And they said, well, you could raise them.
He said, no.
If I stay here, either I'll kill one of them,
or one of them will kill me.
And either way, they'll be doing better to raise my kids.
So we still working on going to Detroit.
And the Ford Motor Company was hiring.
Anybody that showed up on the war tab?
This is going to be on the war too.
Yes.
So we made the arrangements to go to Detroit.
Well, Saturday, a new time was paid day at the factory.
And he says to the boss, oh, well, this is my last day.
What do you mean?
Well, I'm not coming back.
This is it.
That's after you got to check.
So you got to say, Charlie, if you were about that race,
I'll tell you why.
You just put it long in two more hours.
And that would be a really, you have to do the work just long in.
I'm a father, no, this is it.
See, they've got thought he was upset about the race.
But he's upset about the boss sending in word to him to his face.
Right.
And that wasn't the only incident like that.
That kind of stuff happened all the time.
I remember you told one about the gas station once where the...
Yes.
...I just pumped other people's gas and the rest of them sitting there.
Well, my father thought that he was being totally disrespected all the time.
So, when he told the guys, leave it, there's no time.
At six o'clock to Saturday, he got a train to Little Rock.
Okay.
He did for Detroit.
He had a Monday morning, this guy shows up at our house looking for him.
He was from the draft boy.
And he'd go tell my father if he didn't come back to work,
he'd be drafting to the army.
But he was not eligible because he had wife and two kids.
And they weren't drafting those guys like what they didn't care about that.
So, I think my father had a little way back.
But we went to him, my mother's children.
Okay, with the reports for justice.
We're rolling again.
All right, Bill, let's pick up again with the move out of Louisiana.
Your father decided he couldn't stay there.
This is at the beginning of World War II and he moved first to Detroit.
And then from there to Oakland,
and he sent for the family from Oakland.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Well, if you've ever been Detroit in the wintertime,
he said that was killing him, it was too cold.
So, he moved to Oakland, California,
and went to work in Shippewarts.
And he worked in Shippewarts until the war was over.
And then they closed the Shippewarts and did everything stopped, everything.
So, he got an idea, he bought himself a truck.
It sure got out to the belly, which was 45-hour away.
And so, talking to the farmers about getting fruit pickers.
And he made quite a business out of it.
And so, from the time I was after we went back from my mother's children
until I got to college, I always bought my school clothes, picking fruit.
And I was so proud of how much money I could make.
It wasn't even money, but it was up to whatever I could make.
And so, did I enroll in the university?
You know, it was really funny about that.
When I was in Louisiana, my mother kept me away from white people,
which was good.
And she kept white people away from me, because she said,
you don't know what they'll do.
Okay.
And so, well, first of all, the California and Winter School were some white kids.
But then by the time I got to high school, it was an all-black school, except for the faculty.
And then, I went to university, and there were nine black kids on the campus
of a whole student body, and jumped back into that.
And you might say cultural shock.
But I had a pretty good career, and I was self-taught, how to play.
And the reason I say that is, I got cut from the university in the levels of grade.
And so, when I was absorbing this, the varsity coach, who had been my home room teacher in junior high school,
said, to me, I'm glad you got cut.
Why?
Or you glad?
He said, it's because of the day you can come out for the varsity.
I said, I just got cut from junior varsity.
He said, you're not, I'm not a junior varsity coach, I'm a varsity coach.
So, I'm on the varsity.
And he said, I want you to wait up to practice, to first practice.
I said, what is it?
What?
He said, let's go.
He took, got his car, and drove us to the boys' club.
And then he took $2, I was pocket, and bought me a year's membership.
It said, after practice here, I want you to go to the boys' club and play basketball every day.
And so, that's what I did, and that's why I learned to play.
And so, I had a good fortune of not being influenced by a coach.
And so, could you hold up for a second?
Sure.
I was a varsity, all the cliché things that a coach basketball player does, I didn't do any of them.
So, they figured I couldn't play.
So, they did my whole first year, they considered that a waste of scholarship.
And so, my sophomore year, they did not renew my scholarship.
With the coach, Augustus Peter Guilty, he went to the dean of College of Business Administration
and found an unused scholarship.
So, I played my sophomore year, a academic scholarship.
And so, my career, my sophomore year, there were a couple of things that made it interesting.
Four of the top six players on the varsity, my sophomore year, told the coach
that they did not appreciate him making him have to play with black guys.
Now, he never told me that until I had retired from Celtics.
But I know I didn't get alone with these guys.
And a lot of things happened.
I just sit as part of life.
And my first varsity gate, sent a toll of my relationship with the coach.
We played Cal Berkeley.
And the center was a preseason All-American.
The game starts and the first five shots he took, five shots he took, I blocked.
And nobody had built it, never seen anything like that.
So, they called TABOUT to discuss it.
What it was I was doing, because they didn't know what I was doing.
So, we're getting out of the huddle.
And my coach says, you can't play defense like that.
What?
I just stopped in five times a row.
It's not the way to play defense.
So, he showed me on the side of my ass saying, well, I ain't want me to play defense.
So, I'll go back on that track.
And the guy shoots lay up three times in a row.
And I said, this does not make sense.
So, I went back to playing the way I knew how.
He was really insulted by that.
He was trying to help me.
And I was hard-headed and stubborn.
And didn't know what I was doing.
He was trying to help me pick out what I was doing.
And I rejected.
So, he never liked me as a player from then on.
We're talking about the beginning of your basketball career at the University of San Francisco.
Right.
52 to 56.
Basketball was taught differently then.
I mean, some of the things that people now wouldn't be familiar with,
you weren't supposed to leave your feet.
Yeah, no good defensive player ever leaves his feet.
Well, basically, what I was doing in retrospect was bringing the vertical game to the game
that had been in the horror-subtle.
And this is all the good and new elements.
Seeing a high jump, which I had participated in track appeal,
I can jump over my head.
Well, in basketball and Jim, we should do exercise where we take chalk
and put it on your finger and run and jump as high and put a chalk mark.
Well, I can put a chalk mark 13 feet above the floor,
which is the top of the backboard.
And that was going to waste.
So for three years, this coach did not like me.
But I mean about mine, that I was going to see how good I could be.
So I really worked at the BELP and the game
and part of my game was logistics.
So I learned to cover great distances in a short period of time.
And so I developed how to play.
Well, he never agreed with that.
Although, by junior senior year, we won 55 straight games.
Which is not bad.
It was a record at the time.
And we also won back-to-back Final Fours.
And I said a record that still stands today.
In 2013, I had 27 rebounds in the championship game.
And there's still a record.
And I had 50 rebounds into two games.
The semifinals and finals.
But there's still a record.
But my coach was kind of a purest.
This is the way the game was supposed to be played.
And I wasn't doing that.
Some of this, you once said that even before you got to the University of San Francisco
that a lot of your skills in basketball came from mental games
that you were drawing.
You had drawn out of a library and imagining things in art
and on a trip to Northwestern.
At that time, I had the ability to use my imagination.
And so I wanted to strip of these really first class basketball players.
And I watched him do everything.
And I watched the total person, the footwork,
the head thinks, whatever.
Dribbling the whole thing.
And the next day, like a shoot around,
I was trying to do these things.
And so, as I told one of the guys in Oakland,
he said, what about San Francisco?
I said, well, the best way to explain this,
is always what I was going to be when I got there.
You know, and I told you about what we first moved into the projects.
And my mother was getting their apartment together.
And I was sitting on the steps and standing out the way.
And these five guys ran by.
And what I'm slept is he went by.
Well, I was nine years old.
And I didn't know what nine years old was supposed to do.
I wouldn't told my mother.
And she said, what?
She grabbed a key to the house and grabbed me.
We went all through the projects looking for those five guys.
And so she said, these guys, I said, yes, ma'am.
I know what she's going to do.
I thought she's going to take care of it.
But the way she took care of it was,
OK, you're going to find everyone, all five of them one at a time.
Thanks, ma'am.
So I go into five fights.
And I lose three and went to.
And so we go back to our place and I'm crying.
And she says, no cry.
You did what you're supposed to do.
The matter will you want to lose.
The matter is you stood up for yourself.
And that's what you must always do.
Stand up for yourself.
And so that day, she wrote an attitude about,
she says, not a word she's ever ever pick a fight.
But always finish the fight that you end.
And so that's the kind of stuff I got my mother, my father.
And the role was almost reversed.
She told me to be a tough fighter.
And he told me to be philosophical.
Well, he was philosophical.
Yes, he was.
You know, great Taylor, I tell you how my father was.
He would never take anything from me.
I always make a lot of money.
He would never take anything.
He says, this attitude is like I got my own money.
I don't need yours.
So, for his birthday, wasn't you?
I went to a local automobile dealer and bought a car.
And told the salesman, I want you to take this car
and deliver it to this address.
And don't say anything.
The man comes to the door,
have the keys and send us your car and leave.
No explanation.
So, I'll call him up.
I said, did you get the car?
He said, yes.
I just can't believe it about there's something
that nice to put me.
I said, well, it's okay.
So, a week later, he says,
I said, okay, how you doing?
He said, oh, to kick your ass.
What?
What did I do?
He says, I just got my first speed ticket.
That's, that's San Francisco.
I think you once said 1956 was a pretty amazing year in sports.
That's your senior year.
And you were not only in the NCAA Final Four
for the second year in the row of winning it,
but you also went to the Olympics and straight into the NBA.
Right.
Well, we won the Final Four.
Who did you beat?
Who did you remember?
Oh, you know, we beat Iowa.
That's what's it meant, too.
You know, we played this guys
and the guys at Iowa were first class bunch of guys.
You know, in fact, for years,
I kept up with them.
Long after we played against each other.
In fact, my counterpart, Bill Logan, who was a center,
was in Iowa Bank of the Association.
The years later, I went and spoke to him
what their conventions.
Well, anyway, I was on the Olympic team.
And in the gold medal game,
we beat the Soviet Union by 35 points.
We were kind of being guys.
See, in the tournament,
we played a team from Thailand.
Okay.
Their center is 5'10".
And so you would say,
well, these guys are all competition.
That's just walk through it.
No.
Let's find out how bad we can beat these guys.
We were going to try to beat them by 100 points.
I always think we got to be able to 80, 85.
But, uh,
I had a lot of fun.
So after the Olympics,
I went home, got married,
and then went to Boston.
And I had not talked to the Celtics before that.
I was really an amateur.
And I got there,
and we had an idea of what was going to be.
It took about half an hour to work that out.
And so it is 13 months.
We filed for the Olympic gold.
And by rookie year, we won NBA.
So we were the college championship,
the World Amateur Championships,
and the professor championship in 13 months.
And, uh, that's pretty good run.
Is it true that, um, when you went to Boston,
that Walter Brown,
the owner of the Celtics,
and Red Al back in Bill Sharman,
that year at the airport?
Well, I think Red was on the road.
But Bill Sharman,
no, it was all three of you, right?
Red, Walter Brown, and, uh,
Bill Sharman.
Now Walter Brown was,
one of the most marvelous people I've ever encountered.
The owner of the Celtics.
Yes.
Uh,
see there were things that the Celtics did
that, uh,
I don't think it coming knowledge.
The first black player drafted,
it did be a,
was a guy that chucked Cooper from Duques.
The Celtics drafted him.
And at the draft, uh,
one of the other owners said to Walter Brown,
you know he's colored.
And Walter Brown said,
okay, he's poking out.
That's how we drafted.
Okay.
Fast forward.
The Celtics were the first NBA team
to start five black guys.
It was an accident.
Uh, or, or,
surely how the Celtics were.
We, we were doing it for over a week.
And didn't know it until we read about the paper.
She told me Hudson was,
uh, one of the forwards and he got injured.
And so his substitute went in
and filled in until Hudson got back.
And so he had five black guys start.
And, uh,
like I said,
we didn't know about until we read the paper.
Because this was the pop,
these are guys that are rotation, you know.
And so, so now you got,
first black guy signed,
first five black guys started.
We had a guy named Sam Jones
from North Carolina College,
one of quote, traditional Negro colleges.
Well, we drafted Sam in the first round.
That was the first time in any sport
that a guy from one of the Negro colleges
was drafted in the first round.
You see the difference is,
if you drafted the first round,
you're on the team,
you have to play your way off.
If you drafted in the second round,
you got to make the team.
And so your compensation is different.
So, Sam was our first pick.
It turned out to be a great, great pick.
And then,
the Celtics were the first team
to hire black coach.
You? Yeah.
And the way that happened was our back says to me,
I'm retiring.
And I'll have to pick the next coach.
And I will not hire anybody
that you don't want to prove of 100%.
So, he says,
what we're going to do is we're going to make,
you make a list,
and I'll make a list of five guys
that will be okay with you.
And I'll have five guys who are okay with me.
And who else is on both lists?
Is this who gets a job?
Well, there was nobody on both lists.
And so,
Rich says,
well, I'm going to hire this one guy.
I said, Brad, if you hire him,
I will retire with you.
Who's the guy that you think is good coach?
I said, make a difference.
I don't even want to be in the same room with him.
So, he said, well, what am I going to do?
We're going back here to offer me the job first.
And I said, Brad, I want you to step you in through.
No way.
And so, he said, well, what am I going to do?
I said, okay, I'll take it.
I said, here's the deal, though, Rich.
I'll take the job.
If it doesn't work,
we'll know after about an alter game.
And if we agree it's not working,
you can hire anybody who wants,
and I guarantee you to give them 100% cooperation.
But we never got to that.
So, that was the deal.
Yes.
That's 1966, right?
Not only a coach, but a player coach.
What has that had there been other player coaches in the NBA?
I don't know.
You know, I...
A whole assistant coach is, I mean, people today must be shocked.
There are so many, I don't know how many assistant coaches are.
Well, Rich says, do you want to assist it?
I didn't know.
He said, why not?
I said, okay, Rich, give me what you assist us.
Well, Rich had never had an assistant.
Okay.
So, I said, why don't you have an assistant?
He's not just another guy you have to coach.
And...
Well, the atmosphere in Boston
would have been detrimental to the situation I thought
if I had a assistant coach.
Because half a season into it, they said,
well, they had gotten to it on the coach and rushed it just to pick it up.
No better word.
Well, if I was on the coach, I wouldn't be the coach.
Okay.
And so, I should wear a dune.
And it's very interesting that Rich, last year,
as a coach, he got thrown out of 22 games,
including the All-Star Games.
And so, as a captain, I had to take the rest of the game.
So, I went in with some experience on how to do it.
And we had, as a captain,
we used to play Jim Romeo at night after games.
Because neither one was going to sleep after a game.
And we talked about coaching philosophy.
And what he wanted to do was set up a system.
Make sure that everybody knows it.
And they get the hell out of the way.
And that was the way he coached it.
And that's the way he got the team together.
Because I trusted him completely.
And he should do some things that I asked him about.
For example, you know, I played for Boston for 13 seasons.
And during that 13 seasons, we all have made one trade.
And we picked some guys up after they retired.
And we give them another year.
But he never said to anybody,
the way you played there,
you got to play different here.
I got you here because of the way you played there.
So, I don't want you to change.
That's the way I want you to play.
And so, guys did not have to quote the play for themselves.
They did not have to learn a new way of playing.
You got you there where you were before you got here.
And he had a place for you in that system.
Why did he get thrown out of so many games?
Why did great dollar back get thrown out of so many games?
Did it serve a purpose or was it just a personality?
A coalition.
He was never going to the sideline and said,
what the heck?
He says, my team, I can't get my team to fight for me if I won't fight for them.
In fact, my first game,
Riffrey called Goldit-Hinti,
which was not Goldit-Hinti.
Redwood Nuts.
He got to be yelled and screamed and stopped until the Riffrey called it,
that's the melody.
But they were careful after that when they called Goldit-Hinti.
That was his purpose.
And after the game, I said to Red,
you know the first coach that's asked you,
that looked up for me.
He says,
I can't expect my players to fight for me if I won't fight for them.
That's the way I coach.
It wasn't you.
It's thanks Red.
Did you talk a little bit?
You played on the storied Celtic teams,
you won 11 championships in 13 years.
Just a little bit of personality sketches of the various players on the team,
like Sam Jones and, you know, what they were like.
Well, first of all,
more important to me
than when 11 championships.
We weren't eating a roll.
That was difficult.
You know, of course you got to do the same things
with them repeating yourself,
which takes some planning.
Well, I played with some guys that were,
we had a family.
I liked all the guys except for two,
and they were never the who they were.
You know,
at least two I was available about, you know,
Bill Sharman,
most thoughtful player I've played with.
He did everything about it numbers.
And we'd fight at the drop of a hat,
and we were always throwing something else around.
Some braids around.
I think Sharman led the league in fights.
A coupzy could not fight.
So what his ex-red did was very interesting.
We should play Syracuse,
and their guards used to beat up a coupzy.
Just beat him up.
Okay, that's a foul.
We go beat him up.
So Red got so insist about that.
So one night he said, okay,
we had a guy named John Williams,
Luskatov.
Big, look how you've been lifted,
weights and all that.
He says, Luskie, listen.
I want you to watch.
The first guy hits coupzy.
I want you to turn around, knock the hill out of Dorf Shades.
Shades are their best player and he played forward.
So over here he's got to hit coupzy.
What in Shades is that?
What the hell is going on?
Why'd you hit me?
In fact, the next time we played there,
all the fans had cardboard hatchets.
It said, Luskatov was a hatchet man.
But what they had noticed was,
every time the guy had coupzy,
there was a clueless Luskatov to hit Shades.
And so they figured out that maybe we shouldn't have beat them all coups.
And so Red always had a purpose for everything he does.
Good.
So, the coupzy was the star of the Celtics when you arrived.
How did the two of you get along?
Perfect.
There was never any negative exchange between the two of us.
In fact, I took the attitude.
I lived as a proper but,
the coupzy was not a stalwart or defense.
How's that?
Gentle.
But, I never complained to him or to anybody.
I looked at the situation and I was
talking to coupzy about it.
And I said, well,
when this guy comes up and you guard him,
make him go left if he's right-handed.
And as soon as he gets past you, run to the center.
So, I don't want him to be re-throwed or bounce past to the center
because he came through over the top because I won't let it.
So now, coups introduced a lot of...
intercepted a lot of passes because they tried to throw a bounce pass
and he was in the lane.
And so, I should lead the way in block shots.
Well, a great majority of them were all coupsies, man.
And we turned that and then he and I were talking.
And one day he says, you know,
on the rebounds and block shots, you come on the ball,
you're looking for me.
When the shots taken, I'll run over to this spot over here.
It's halfway between the free throw line and the half court on the left side.
And so, if we were to road, I'd look for the green.
Then, the car ride and have to turn around and look,
I could kiss the ball, kiss the rebound and just change direction.
He would take two dribbles in him, we have to lay up.
And so, I felt...
See, my whole thing was, I found out that in order to get any recognition,
I would have to change my complexion.
And so, what I decided to do,
and that was in college, also, trying to win every game.
And so, with my career's over, they said, so and so is better.
He's better and he's better.
In fact, my second year of the league, the players,
and those days, we had to vote for the MVP.
You could not vote for your own team,
but you could vote for anybody you wanted.
Well, I was overwhelmed with MVP.
It wasn't even closer.
The riders, on the media, wherever you call them,
picked me second team on league.
So, I think I'm still the only guy to ever win the MVP,
and be second team on league.
And so, I wasn't going to let that bother me.
Of course, my emphasis was on winning on the team game.
Why did Kuzi never referred to Red R back as Red?
Is that right? He had eccentricities.
What do you call him Arnold?
Yes.
Well, they had a start out of a kind of a shaky relationship,
but he bothered to a good relationship.
When Kuzi was a senior at Kohli Cross,
Red had, when he came to his pick, he did not pick Kuzi.
And because Red's theory about winning was
put a team together that could play against the best team,
and the rest would take care of itself.
Which is solid, I think.
Well, the dominant player was the guy that enjoyed his mind-canned,
and certainly one of the big guys that ever played NBA.
So, there was a kid who had been a big guy from Bowling Green,
who could match back at physically, and he had some skills.
So, Red drafted him.
And I said, well, what happened?
I said, well, the press in Boston tried to crucify Red.
Of course, they said, how stupid he was, not to draft Kuzi.
But everybody knew he was the best player in the world.
So, Red said, well, that's the way I wanted it.
I said, well, I think I should do it.
Well, the guy said, well, we're going to run you out of town.
You've insulted all of us.
How's that?
You're a Jew?
And we don't like Jews either.
So, as Red, how'd you handle that?
I'll just leave the bastards.
So, he had some of Mr. Charlie's advice, your mother's advice.
That's their little Red Wagon.
How's that?
Oh, yeah, that's, you know, see, Red knew what he was doing.
You know, I don't know most people know this.
Red needs to practice with us.
He's a decent shooter.
And we had a game we played 21.
And he'd be out there with us all the time.
So, he played Kuzi's ball.
In fact, my first tournament in college was all Kuzi's tournament
in Oklahoma City.
And, uh, very interesting.
The coach of Wichita, who was, uh, was 18.
We were seeing it eighth.
And Wichita was seeing it one.
So, what they do to you, if you see it eighth, they throw you to the wolves.
You have to play the first top 17, the first game.
So, they, it's like a warmo for them.
Okay.
So, because, since he never heard of the USF, he thought it was San Francisco State.
Well, the government's return, but he found out it was USF.
So, he said his brother out to scout us.
Well, if he picked the last game we lost in college.
It's a scum.
UCLA and Westwood.
So, he says, guys, I don't know what they're thinking about these guys.
This is just before the game.
He said, I don't know what they're thinking about these guys, but, uh,
my brother's scum, but he's going to give me a quick rundown.
So, the brother said, well, guys, I don't know how to tell you this, but
these guys cannot play a lick.
In fact, most of the good high school teams in the state of Kansas can beat these guys.
They got two guards, we changed one of the guards since the last game that we lost.
And, uh, said the two guards came put in the ball in the ocean.
Well, one of those guards was a guy that had Casey Jones.
Who was a fair player?
He said, they got this tall, colored, cute, and play center.
He does not do anything.
And they never pass in the ball.
And now, since the time I never got, they never had a play for me to shoot.
So, all he does is stand around, and he jumps a lot.
Sometime for no reason, he just stand there and jump.
And so, don't worry about it.
Just go out and just run about a gym, and then the rest of the game.
I don't think that coach can play you, start it over 15 minutes.
So, the game starts.
Three minutes into the game, they called time out.
The score was 25 to three.
They couldn't, first of all, Casey Perry, four court press.
They couldn't get the ball of half court.
And when they got over half court, they threw a shot out of blockade.
They just threw the shot out of the blockade, and then they got the ball.
And they were just, they were just shooting, they were just shooting.
And so, it was disaster for them.
Half time, we were 30 points ahead.
And then, in the next game, we played Oklahoma City University.
And that was, we only beat them by 19.
And then, we played with the college.
And he played for his coach and still coach him.
And so, start a second half, we scored him 22 to 1.
And so, after the game,
Rodhart, Rich Old Coach, college coach called Red Up at midnight.
They read.
They just saw something.
I just saw the player.
That's the one you want to get for the Celtics.
Now, he's a junior.
So, you got two years to figure out how to get him for your team.
And so, that's when Rich started working on getting me to Boston.
You lost, wasn't it?
You know, it's amazing to me.
You're talking about games over nearly 60 years ago.
Do you think any athlete at the level you play remembers the,
they're still vivid to you?
Well, you know, I tell you what, my, my late wife,
was always trying to do something for me.
And so, she, she, I want to, both of us got computers, same time.
And she had a computer, I had my computer.
And so, and learned her computer, she started going on eBay.
And she was there, and she said,
so one day she says,
she says, I've got something for you.
Who said, it's the best ball game,
University of San Francisco, 1955.
And I think you would cause it,
and play at University of San Francisco.
So, we have a video of it, a tape.
So, we sat out and turned it on,
and I said, oh, that's Oregon State, and USM.
She said, how'd you know?
I said, I just saw that introduction.
And I told her,
truthfully, every play before it happened, but the whole game.
And she said, now, how did you remember that?
That was 40 or 50 years ago.
I said, there was a time before I tried to consciously stop doing it.
I remember every play of every game I ever played.
I did that for scouting purposes.
So that, if I play this guy again,
I know exactly what he does.
See, because my defense was not reaction.
It was action.
You come up to me, Taylor, and your player,
and you have a shot you wore, I don't know.
I'm going to make you take a shot, I want you to take it.
And then I played that.
That's a remarkable way your brain works, though.
The only thing that I know that's comparable to it is friends of mine
who can remember the lyrics of every music, you know,
because that's an emotional tie.
Their head is stuffed with lyrics from music from their childhood,
but you can remember plays over a long career like that.
Even now, I've tried constantly to forget most of them.
I remember plays that I did in high school.
The game that I got, the scholarship from,
we were playing Oakland High at Oakland High.
And I had one, three, and five leading scores of the conference on my team.
So there was not much left over.
Okay.
So we had a close game in the first half.
I scored the last three baskets of the first half.
So we went into the second half of one point.
We get down to the last few minutes,
and I scored the last four baskets for my team.
And we were about one point, I think it was.
When I remember everyone was playing.
And there were also plays to get them off at the rebounds.
But both of the scouting for me,
of course, I was never going to be reacting the second time I played against you.
The first time you might do a move and, hey, okay, don't do it again.
I had McClellan just for historical purposes.
And McClellan's your high school.
You were there at the same time Frank Robinson, the baseball player.
What did you know him?
Well, of course, Frank, today, if I run to Frank Hill, tell me,
you know I've been the best ball player in the U.N. McLean.
Which remarkable about Frank is a really good guy.
And my coach at high school was wonderful, wonderful bad.
He was the only white guy.
There were little black kids playing on his American Legion team.
And so at one time he had 13 guys in the Major League.
And Frank was one of the major pensions.
And more than just as important, a guy named Kurt Flood.
These guys are, and I'll tell you truth, what we were in high school.
Frank was a great player.
But all we ever heard about was a guy named James W. Porter.
He played for Oakland Tech, a big red-handed guy.
And according to the local press, the American Walker Award,
I would not get his ankle through it.
But Frank, you know, he might have been all city,
but GW was a man.
Well, I tell you story about Frank, if you don't mind.
With a golf tournament, got a San Diego,
sent to my right as Frank Roberts.
She went to my left, Bob Gibson.
A Hall of Fame pitcher.
So I brought up a conversation.
I said, Frank, don't you hold a record for the most hit by a pitcher in the Major League?
He said, yeah.
I said, who would you do both?
So Bob Gibson was one of the few college guys in the Major League,
when he was in Major League.
So Bob was embarrassed by this.
He was sincerely embarrassed.
So he says to me, Bill, let me tell you,
I did not want to hit him all those times.
So with Frank, put his left elbow over the plate.
So he took away the inside pitch.
You couldn't throw inside, of course, he was up over the plate.
If you threw the inside pitch, you hit him.
So he says, one day I just said it, I'm just not going to hit him anymore.
I'm just not going to do that.
So I threw a pitch on the outside.
We never did find that baseball.
He said, well, I guess I'll have to hit him.
Have you ever felt, was it at the USF?
You also high jumped with Johnny Mathis, the singer?
Well, you got it backwards.
I got it backwards. He high jumped with you.
No, I was just kidding.
No, he's been a friend for at least 60 years.
He was a good high jumper.
I was in the top five in the world.
I grew up in freshman year.
And I went to a track meetup at University of Nevada, Reno.
And I set the field record in high jump.
It was the last three weeks.
Johnny Mathis went up there and broke it.
And I never forgave him for that either.
But he played his good basketball player.
So we had a summer league and he played in it.
So we had an awards dinner.
So all the guys in the league went to his dinner.
And so for entertainment in his dinner, the MC said,
we're going to have one of our participants sing a song for us.
Oh boy.
You know, no, I know, you know, you're in the basketball player that could sing.
Okay.
So he gets up, acapella,
and sings strange and paradise.
After the song did silence.
Nobody in the place could believe what we just heard.
You know, he was so good.
And nobody in suspect that he could sing.
And uh,
but so numbers were ever surprised when he went on to this great career.
He has had a great career since.
Let's cover just a few of the other Celtics played with the new personality sketches of,
you talked about Sam Jones a little bit, but I think I remember you were saying that he could be
exasperating because on the one hand, he was a great leader.
On the other hand, you were telling to call the plays and you would say,
I don't call the plays.
Well, you start out when Sam was a rookie.
In practice,
Sam was as good a player as I'd ever seen.
Okay.
So I let him, because the way the sound structure was,
you didn't get paid until the season started.
So all through training camp, all you got was me, oh buddy.
So,
I brought Sam home with me and they'd stay with me until he started getting paid.
Okay.
So all the way home after practice, I said,
Sam, you can really play.
He said, I know it.
So I said,
why don't you play like that all the time?
You could be first team all league.
You could make a lot of money.
He said, I don't want to do that.
I said, why not?
I do not want to have to play like that every day.
He said, that's where you are as much as playing.
The responsibility of him.
You know that if you don't play well, the team not doing well.
I said, okay, Sam, I can live with that.
And so, Sam could have been one of the,
I thought, well, the all time greats,
if he had wanted to,
he, all of it was great.
I thought,
because,
in our run of,
he was on 10 champs, he had 10.
He was never an innocent bus stander.
And at least six times, I can recall,
Sam took the shot that meant the season.
And he never hesitated to take the shot,
and he never missed.
Now, a couple of other guys were like Tom Hyneson.
Everybody thought of him as a big, rough, hard-knows guy.
Tommy was an artist and a poet.
He said, Hyneson, a poet.
You know,
and one of the all time, for me,
well, they all time good guys.
Okay?
And what about teammate?
What about favorite teammates?
You said that Red had to motivate him differently than he would.
Oh, yeah.
Well, Ray, we had a system he'd figure out.
Part of his strategy was,
how many men can you play in a row and be effective?
And so he'd start Hyneson, and in a six minute, he'd take him out.
And no matter how he's playing.
And so Hyneson said,
great public statement,
red you hold me up to public score.
And Red says,
he'll say, why are you taking about six minutes?
If he's playing good, he's tired.
If he's not playing good,
I mean, if he's not tired, he ain't playing good.
So, at six minutes, get him out of there.
And so Hyneson considered Red using him as a whipping boy.
And there was some justification for finger that way.
You know, but Red actually really cared for the players.
What about Ramsey?
No, Ramsey.
Frank Ramsey.
We got a loan from the first moment he met.
And of course, Frank and I were only interested in,
we're both interested in,
we're interested in one thing, winning.
And that's his whole thing.
Now Red used a, I call it,
almost a second job,
but Frank is too smart to use the second job.
Frank, well, when he got there, he had been in the Army.
And he got there, he was playing with us on weekend passes.
So, we've always come out of the bench.
And so,
next year, Sam, Frank has come out of the bench.
And Red talks to him and says,
now,
you should be a starter.
And I will never refer to you as second team.
I will call you my sixth starter.
And you will always be my first substitute.
Well, that took care of all of us had eagles.
It always wanted to be started or whatever.
So, Frank bought it.
So, Frank,
for a solidified six-man.
In fact, they named it an award,
and then the after-hit Frank started.
And I'll never give one night out of that,
or my front teeth knocked out.
I never had anything that could happen.
So, I look at this,
or my front teeth in my hand.
And I don't know what to do.
Like, look at that.
And Frank took out his bridge,
who was both his front teeth.
He said, here, look at that.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
You know what was really funny was.
His coach had said they shouldn't let these black guys play,
or the Ju Zina,
and are coming from that atmosphere.
Frank and I were ever disgusting.
We were teammates,
we just, I dear, both were,
and both of us showed the other guy,
completely total respect.
You know, and I never get after one of our championships.
Frank says, hey, Russ,
after seeing this over,
why don't you come down and spend a week with me down in Kentucky?
I said, Frank,
you're a good guy.
There's no way hell over goes for no week in Kentucky.
How about Habler Check?
He took that six-man role from Ramsey, right?
Frank showed him how to do it.
And as Habler Check had played in college,
you always hit the open man.
Well, in Pro Ball,
you set up to the best shooting gear shots, you know.
And so we give him,
Habler Check the Ball,
and nobody ever had a 10 feet.
And he looked for somebody to pass to.
Habler Check shoot the ball.
Okay, okay.
So this is going on for a while.
So one night he took us up,
shot 38 times.
So, you sure kind of guys we were,
what kind of team we had?
We'd get the trainer to lead you to best early,
and go to a locker room,
and fill a tub with ice.
And so we came out of the game, after the game,
we all iceed down Habler Check's arm.
Because he had shots over the yard.
Well, you know,
we all had something we did well,
and we always tried to put our teammates in a position
to do what they did well,
so that every play
consists of five guys doing something.
And so that,
when you got an overshot,
because we all worked to get you an overshot.
And that was part of our thing.
And it's like we almost developed
what we call the Celtic way.
It's that the attitude was
be kind to your teammates.
Now what does it sound like in Pro-Ball?
Well, what do you mean by be kind?
Well, first of all, what is kindness?
Kindness is an act of strength.
I can do this, and I will do that.
That's strength and kindness.
So,
like,
Satch was guarding the Bill Bradley one day.
He didn't met the Square Garden.
And he and Bradley were shooting about the gym.
I mean, he was good moving without the ball.
So, I said, Satch,
Satch,
this is a time when I said,
there's something you ought to know.
On the Nicaragua uniforms,
little small, little men front
and a big number on the back.
I knew he hadn't seen that small number.
But there is one.
So, story happened.
Bill Bradley told me about it.
That same game.
Bradley's having a good night.
So, we light up a free throws,
we're being brothers on that side.
Satch and Bradley, oh, the other side.
That was a captain, so,
I'll go tie about.
I'll walk across the lane.
Now, I don't know if this leg was just okay for your thing, here.
I think it'll be alright.
So, I walk over to Satch,
and Bradley, who told me the story later,
because I've pointed to this,
and Bradley says,
you go out there and buy the fucker.
But that's shocked Bradley.
He'd never been called that before.
There was the idea.
Satch said, yeah, I said, we're going to God damn it.
It would be across the lane.
And Bill Bradley told the story later,
and he never hit another shot.
He said, because I had thrown him off.
And that was the idea of,
we should try all kind of weird things to get...
So, your comment was aimed at Bradley, not for Satch.
Oh, yeah, Satch.
Right, look at the Satch, but I was aimed at Bradley.
Yeah, yeah.
We're rolling again.
So, I'd like to shift a little bit to talking about race themes.
You've talked about them a little bit growing up,
that your mom didn't want you around white folks,
and that when you went to the USF for the first time,
you're in a sea of white folks in Jesuits,
taboo, you're on a Jesuit campus there at San Francisco.
But, obviously, you've dealt with race your whole life.
And you've talked that you've...
When we've discussed it,
then basically about perspective,
and how people see things,
and what people are not conscious of.
If I'm not mistaken,
you said that the first time you went to the movies,
then you saw King Kong, the movie,
came out of there with a different perspective
than anybody else in the theater.
Yeah, I think so.
And I think it is his big ol' gorilla, okay?
That he's been taking these sacrifices,
obviously for years and years.
The first time they put away, well, I'm not there,
he fell in love with it.
No, I just thought that was all I'd...
But most people didn't.
Most people saw that as the romance of the film.
You said that often that he'd had sacrifices
and the African women,
that he would come and take them and kill them,
and probably eat them,
but the first time he puts a white woman out there,
he falls in love with his food.
So it's just how people look at things
and what people take for granted.
You said, was it your high school coach
that said you can't fight on the basketball court,
because if black kids fight, it's a riot,
and if black kids fight, it's a skull.
Yeah, this is the same guy that my high school coach,
he says, let's keep things in perspective.
No fighting.
It's not because I'm afraid that you're afraid.
I don't think that at all.
But if we get into three fights,
we are butchered thugs.
And you know, no matter how well we play,
just those thugs from the club.
Well, so when they find out how good you are,
they'll be gathered and try to pick a fight,
because that's the only way they can think they can beat.
Well, when they try to pick a fight,
you don't fight.
You don't fight on the hard side.
And you beat them with a game of basketball.
You have to play harder because in effect,
you have to make up for that.
Well, I know when I was a rookie with the Celtics,
none of my other league had ever seen me play,
because I played on a West Coast.
So this guy playing against Toby this story years later.
He was a center for the Fort Wayne Pistons,
then before it was Detroit.
And we started the game, he never seen me play.
And the first five shots he took, I blocked him.
With his coach, he had been a referee.
He had a real scratchy voice.
And you can hear him all over the gym.
And he says, you ought to be ashamed of that rookie embarrassed you like that.
Damn rookie, look at him, maybe you look bad.
You embarrassed all of us.
And so this guy, listen, this is for about five minutes.
And he says, now I got to get out of this.
What am I going to do?
Okay.
I know that he will fight.
So I'm going to hit him.
We're going to fight, we're both going to throw it out of the game.
But fight.
There were a couple of things he did not know.
I would never fight in the first quarter.
We get to the last quarter now, we can talk about it.
Okay.
So he just turned around and hit me in the chest.
Wack!
Knocked my breast out of me.
As I just looked at him,
and I didn't say a word because I used to never talk.
And so, what he did not know,
that between high school and college,
I had worked in the shipyards.
Sounds like school, maybe with shipyard.
And we had a lunchtime volleyball competition.
And so, I learned how to spike the ball.
You know, we better unspiking.
So, the next time we shot,
our spectra read it his head.
That's no foul.
This is competition.
The next three times we shot,
the third time we shot and ducked.
Speaking of race in basketball,
I want to transition after the break to talk a little bit about your time in Boston.
The Celtics, as you said earlier,
were the first team in the NBA to draft a black player.
They were also Boston,
the Red Sox were the last baseball team to take a black player.
Not until night, 12 years after Jackie Robinson,
that they get Pumpsy Green.
So, when you were in Boston,
it was a city that was just in two sports teams,
where the first and last on that.
How racial, how did you learn about race in Boston?
Well, they didn't take very long.
You know,
like I long enough, I got to, they stored having problems with the bussing.
And all that kind of stuff.
They were very negative about it.
And a couple of sports writers told Heisen
that they were never booked for me for anything.
Okay?
I'll give you an example.
1969.
We were the second championship in a row.
Okay?
They had a parade on Friday.
Friday afternoon.
Friday morning, a reporter from the Boston Herald
walked into Red's office and said,
are you satisfied with the coaching you had this year?
Rest of the way, tell you what to talk about.
We just won a championship.
He said, yeah, but if you had a better coach,
couldn't you have one more regency in games?
All it was, they did not want Bill Russell
or any black guy coaching their Celtics,
which finally become theirs.
It red says to me, calls me up at the guy leaves.
He says, do you believe this?
I said, red does make a difference.
I'm not going to do this step in a boy anyway.
That's how I was retiring.
And the reason I never said anything about retiring before,
it had been a tradition for the Celtics.
The guys announced before the last season,
before the season starts, this will be their last year.
Well Sam Johnson announced that this will be his last year.
There's no way I'll throw whatever red does Sam's parade.
And say, well, I'm retiring too.
No, no, that's not, you can't do that.
You know, I'm not the player I have in such a high state,
but Sam Jones.
So the rinse is to me.
Don't tell anybody, because I got to try to change your mind.
Taking our respectful red was,
he never ever mentioned that again.
You know, and of course,
when he decided to retire as a coach,
I said, red, why don't you coach one more year,
and I can retire with you.
He says, no, I'm headed, this is it.
And I never brought that up again.
Of course, I respect that he was a,
and tells a thoughtful man,
and if he decided to do that,
or he could do it,
it's been great fun, Red.
That's all you could do.
And that's the same thing he said with me.
You know, you know,
in fact, tell you how the shelters worked for me.
I called myself, this Walter Brown and Red all back.
In the middle 60s,
Walter Brown called me up,
and says, I need to talk to you.
Okay.
When you want to do it,
he says, well, where can you get in here?
I say, well, Walter, I don't have a job.
I can come in right now.
He says, well, wait for you.
So I go in to Walter Brown's office,
and he's sitting there with his desk,
his full of papers, and stuff.
He says, he's seen his papers?
Oh, sure. Yeah.
Not very neat.
He says, those are the papers of the Boston Celtics,
those are the books of the Boston Celtics.
And the reason I'm sure of them to you is,
I want you to go through them.
We don't pay you enough.
You know it.
I know it.
And anybody that interested knows
that we don't pay you enough.
But I'm always, I'm already paying you more
than I can afford,
because we lose the money.
But I want you to know that
we know that you're on the page,
and we can't afford to pay you more now.
But as soon as we make it up money,
we can't make it up to you.
And he says, of course,
you never held us up.
You could have held us up,
but you didn't.
And I want you to know that I appreciate it.
As a consequence, after Walter died,
my last contract with the Celtics
red gave me an eight-year
no-cut contract at 35.
That means I could pay for the Celtics
if I wanted to until I was 43.
But in order to collect it,
I did not have to play.
I could bring my doctorate
and say, I want to play this year.
But my doctor says he doesn't think I can do it.
Then he got to pay me for that year.
Well, I only played one year of that contract
and then I left.
And they say, well, why don't you take the money?
I said, I could not take the money
that I did not earn.
I could have my father.
Yeah. Same reason.
He didn't want your money.
Right.
All right. Let's take a break.
Is that all right?
Okay. We're going now.
Let's talk some about your philosophical views
and also public life outside of sports.
We're going to talk more about sports, too.
From very early on,
it seemed to me that you started thinking about how sports fit
into other life.
You used to say even that sports was a mixture of art and war
and that it was like politics, religion, and the arts
that sports could gather people.
When did you start thinking philosophically
about the place of sports in life?
Well, I think it was my house
because there was no fighting.
You understand me?
And you have to be aware.
I think the key phrase to me has been,
it is far more important to understand
than it is to be understood.
And so,
take things as they come.
It's like you're walking to this room,
and it is.
Now what's good or bad
is your perception.
Right or wrong is your perception.
And after you make adjustments,
the next question is,
what are you going to do about it?
Okay.
So,
now,
if you lose control,
you'll end your life
being a better annoyed old man.
But if you take control of your life as much as possible,
because you understand,
then you didn't have a chance to be happy.
You know, of course,
now,
when I was in college,
I found out that
there were not any blacks,
there were tougher there for you,
no matter what sport.
Now,
you take Willie Mason Mickey Mathall.
If Willie Mason had a hundred home runs
with a season,
Mickey Math will still have been the best baseball player.
Now, really could get annoyed by that,
or he just goes out and says,
well, next year I have to hit 200.
And so,
like,
my junior in college,
I'm able to tell you about it.
We were 28 and 1.
We won the foul 4.
I was not standing player in the foul 4.
I was first team all-American.
I have 20 points and 20 rebounds,
and they never kind of blocked shots until four or five
years after retirement from the NBA.
Okay.
So, first team all-American.
We go to Northern California,
sports back with,
and he picked another center's player in the year.
Now,
I could have been injured.
But what I did,
for me, eternally,
I dismissed that award
as something that I would like.
And I really was able to do that.
And so,
I had met up by my,
that I was going to be
the best basketball player I could be.
And
this team,
I have no regard for the coach on the rest of the players.
All I thought about was being the best basketball player I could be.
Well, I was very good,
and made my team win.
But,
I wasn't gonna let all my self-esteem
be tied up on what other said about what I was doing.
You should just like,
you said that the Celtics
had more fun than any team around.
Was that essential to winning or was that an accident?
I think it was essential to winning.
Because,
it based out overballed,
but we actually looked out for each other.
And if a guy was having a bad night,
we were constantly always use humor.
Toughening humor, right?
You made a ton of it.
You couldn't have to be thin skinned and be a Celtic, right?
Well, you know,
I know if a guy's having a bad time,
and he's hurting our team,
how can we help him out?
Well, first of all,
it could help him out physically.
But let him know that mentally,
we were,
therefore, if he needed help,
we'll give it to him.
And he should not be ashamed to ask for help.
You see,
in the martial world,
men are usually reluctant to ask for help.
Well,
one night we planned to pillage off you
six years in Boston Garden.
And I was doing my very best,
and not that well,
Garden Wheel Table.
I knew it, he knew it,
and everybody built it.
So,
I kept hearing his walk,
walk, walk, walk,
and what it was,
Casey was trying to help me out.
So, every time he went by a world, he did it.
And so,
I looked back and Casey got by a walk,
and I said,
I said,
I'm out,
we're going to mention,
what's the word?
I said,
excuse me.
Casey, what are you doing?
He said,
what's the matter?
You afraid Big fella?
I said, you got there right out.
I said, you go right ahead,
I got the rest of them
with their big marks the whole night.
Like,
I said,
it's hard enough,
but you go get them riled up
and make them easy and make them impossible.
And so,
it was Casey,
taking a chance to get to their fight,
to help me.
Because he could see,
I needed help.
You know,
and he went all through the lineup, that's great.
When you were coming up into,
into the pro sports,
did you have any role models
or athletes that you look up to
at all, like Jackie Robinson?
Uh, were Jackie,
of course,
and basketball,
and got him George Mac care.
The center for the Minneapolis Lakers?
Well, you know,
when he started playing football,
his folks thought
he was going through a seminary
to be a priest.
And so, as far as they're doing,
they're like,
George,
there's a guy with the same name as you
playing football.
And they were shocked,
and he was,
there was that son that was playing for the ball.
And, uh,
we see, when I was a kid in Oakland,
in elementary and junior high school, especially,
Oakland had a major,
minor league baseball team,
the Oakland A-Coreers,
who played in Henryville.
Where we used to go out there,
we couldn't afford to go into park.
And we waited and see if anybody had a home run,
you could take their ball and go in and get in.
I had to show.
But we found
that there were creatures
that were ever invading the earth
with minor league baseball players.
They would come out of the games
and they'd see us,
and they'd call us the N-word,
spit tobacco at us,
and then we could actually
collect indecently.
So my view of the Professor athletes
was not positive at all.
So when I went to the next
abusive game,
the linkers were playing.
And, there's a guy that said,
he played high school ball with Jim Pollard.
He was a big star with the linkers.
And he was going to go to the locker's house.
And so I say, I'll wait out here.
Three goes in there.
And so while I was waiting, George Mackey comes out.
He sees me and he walks over me.
How you doing, Big fella?
Well, that was a real joke.
Mac was 6'10 to 80.
And I was 6'700.
And he says, how you doing, Big fella?
He said, you play center?
I said, yeah.
He said, well, he showed me a couple moves that he used.
And says, now listen.
When you get out of college, you got to come play for the Lakers.
And I couldn't even make my home room team.
And college was, I had no scholarships or nothing.
And so I'd be working a shipyard saving up money to go to college.
I was going to pay my own way.
So Mac is just, after you got a college, you got to come play for the Lakers.
And that was it.
He was the number one guy in basketball.
And he talked so nice to me.
He wasn't condescending or anything.
He was talking to me like off the little ball player.
Well, that's going back more than 50, 60 years or something like that.
And we think race relations would have been horrible back then.
And they were because you've never been rosy about it.
But you're saying that even back in those periods, there are always exceptions to the rules.
Well, you know, remember I tell you, his folk story is going to be in the seminary.
But he was just a good person.
And I tell you, one of the greatest rewards I had was after George died, he had a private
ceremony for his family.
And I was invited.
Of course, George and I had been friends.
You know, we had a thing in LA we did on TV show or something.
And George says, Bill, I want you to do me a big favor.
I need a big favor from you.
I'll let him say if you said no.
I said, what's it, George?
He said, I don't want to introduce you to my son.
Are you kidding?
That's a favor.
You know?
So he introduced me to his son.
And he says to his son, I want you to meet Bill Russell.
The greatest son of him, he played basketball.
And I said, George, people forget.
You know, he won three championships in five years.
He was the man in basketball.
But it wasn't on television, all that.
So I suppose people didn't know that.
But I was so flattered that this man had been so nice to me.
You know, a lot of people say very, very sensitive things to kids.
And I hope that I never do that.
You know?
Because you can injure kids.
But I have this thing that I get along.
But the first thing I need about, is your second thought.
Because the first one is the one that might injure kids.
Yeah, are you new?
Yeah.
I think one of your sayings was always that you don't believe there's any such thing as
other people's kids.
Right.
Well, I'm speaking at a school in Fort Worth, Texas.
And there was a day where winding down the Vietnam War.
And I said, it's still a spread of other money, killer of peasants.
We should take that money and re-pair an educational system.
Because we haven't paid enough attention to it.
We haven't paid enough money to it.
And so after the speech, you know, one guy comes and says, well, listen.
Your speech is already except for one thing.
What you talk about is raising my taxes.
And why should I pay taxes to educate other people's kids?
And I said to him, two reasons you should pay taxes.
One, when you were six and you first bottled you up and said you're off to school, there
was a school there for you to go to.
And you're fostered that building.
It was there.
And second, there are no other people's kids in the other states.
This next generation of Americans.
And if we don't educate them, we lose all the things that we think are important.
Because if we do not want to top educated societies, we will not be able to compete internationally.
And so we have a choice of either building our schools or picking a war.
And I don't think picking a war is the best option.
We can talk a little bit about your relationship to the civil rights movement.
I know because that was during your play and career.
It was around for a lot of it.
I know once you went to Mississippi in the summer of 1964 for Charles Evers, the brother
of Medgar Evers a year after he was killed.
Well, you know, I was never big on organizations.
And the reason for that was if you say something as part of an organization, you can be dismissed
as a mouthpiece for an organization.
And so they don't have to deal with what you're saying.
When Medgar Evers got shot, we had a moral service for him in Boston.
At the Boston government.
And I said next to Charlie Evers his brother.
And so I don't know what I was thinking.
Well, I told him does everything I can do.
Here's my home number.
He used it.
So he called me.
That's something says we're taking a hit.
More relwized.
And we're down to the lowest we've been.
And so we need somebody to give us a boost.
To show somebody from outside cares.
Sure, I said, okay, what do you want me to do?
He says, you know what would be a good idea.
And in your field of expertise, why don't you do some basic medical clinics in Jackson,
Mississippi, in Toronto, in fight everybody?
Any kid that wants to come, can come to your clinics.
I said I can do that.
So I went down to did clinics.
I actually joined myself.
And Charlie says to me, you know we're not going to do anything happen to you.
I said, okay.
And so I had armed guards.
But they were like the secret service you never knew they were around.
And they gave me such.
Oh, the high.
1964, this is Mississippi Freedom Summer.
They were in our chanee in Goodland, the first three civil rights workers on the very
first night were murdered.
It was a frightful place to be going to.
Yes.
You're not exactly inconspicuous.
Well, you know, I was invited years later to the McDonald's High School All-Star
Game, okay, in Indiana.
And so I went there and I had a good time.
And after I spoke, they asked me to take pictures.
I'll picture with each one of the participants.
Boys and girls.
It was two games.
A boys and two game and a girls game.
So while the female high school player of the year was a young lady from Colorado.
And so she was while I said the picture up, she says, Mr. Russell, I like to say something to you.
You said something to that in your speech that I would carry with me for the rest of my
life.
What?
She said to us, do not be afraid.
Because all decisions made out of fear are usually bad decisions.
And you're going to a new world from high school to college, into college, into the world.
Do not be afraid.
Because you're all right.
You got this far?
Do not be afraid.
Well, I may be not too bright, but I cannot recall the rest of how I was afraid.
I would be shy to live in.
Every time I could do something, I see it as an opportunity.
Could you tell me a little bit about your relationships with other civil rights figures from that
area that you have a neat Malcolm X or Martin Luther King?
Well, I just briefly knew Malcolm X.
I know Louis Farricot.
He's been to a house a few times.
He came out with...
Before he changed his mind, he was cash his claim.
And the reason cash was covered by house was...
I was a gold medal winner in the 56 Olympics.
And I always had affection for gold medal winners.
Because I knew what it takes.
And so I knew the last...
Much of Washington.
I stayed the same hotel as Reverend Martin Luther King.
And so we met in lobby and had a brief conversation.
And I told him I was there for the march.
And he invited me to gold stage with what he made a big speech.
And I respectfully declined.
And the reason I declined was they had worked for a couple of years to put their thing together.
And I hadn't done anything.
And it would not be right.
I didn't think...
For a mean gold stage and say, hey listen, this is what we've done.
And I hadn't done anything.
So I said the first role.
I had enjoyed it, but I didn't want to be one of those guys.
Hey look at me.
You know if there's a photograph of you at the Margeone Washington.
Have you ever seen one?
What's that?
You know if there's a photograph of you there.
I don't know. I don't think so.
I'd love to see that.
I don't think so.
I was just one of the guys.
I was one of the people.
They're to support that.
And when he was killed that's during the season and your next the last year I guess.
Yeah. Well, when he was killed, we would play the game the night he got killed.
It filled it off here.
And they asked us.
They asked both teams.
What do you think?
You think we should call the game off?
Or play?
Now we think it would be a bad thing for the city of Philadelphia.
If we call the game off and you got 12 or 13,000 people on the great stress.
And really, really annoyed.
That's a quiet way of putting it.
On the streets.
And so we said, well, we'll do is we play the game and we keep these 12 or 13,000 people in the game in time to cool off.
So that you don't have riots in the street.
That's the reason we played that game.
Then we didn't play for a week or so.
But we do some things we thought about.
Did you know I'll leave much after you?
When you said, oh, yeah, I do him when he was a kid boxer.
And I always a fan.
Of course, to reach the top of your field.
It takes more than physical ability.
You have to know what you're doing to get to the top of your field no matter what the field.
Because there are things you have to do to execute what it takes to be the top of your field.
And so, our lead was not only a great, great boxer.
But he's a psychologist and a brave, brave man.
I was in Boston with the guy says, I want you to disobey Muhammad Ali.
What? I want you to put him in this place.
So I'm not going to do anything like that.
He said, you want me to just a bar? I said, no.
He said, well, I think you ought to do that.
I said, I don't care what you think.
If I had a choice between you and Ali, you would even erase.
Are you kidding?
So he started calling me felton X after that.
You know, there's the call of Muslims with an X.
You know, Malcolm X and all that.
You know, uh,
Didn't you, when he got drafted, didn't you organize a group of, I didn't organize your brown organize.
Him brown organized, but you joined it.
Oh, yeah.
Just to support his decision.
Yes. What you see the thing is, what you have to think about is,
well, this decision, not to go into the army.
If you read what it was based on,
arbitrarily, they decided to change his status without a hearing or anything.
Just we're going to change it.
Well, that's not right.
You know, from what, uh, what category was it?
I'm not sure, but they changed it to one A.
So could I go put you in army?
Well, you can't do that.
You know, you know, there's a,
was that?
I'm groping for it was a way to ask what was the time that you felt was most controversial, your most controversial stance.
Who me?
Yeah, in your career when you got the most heat for something that you felt or believed or said or didn't say.
Well, I started with,
when I got the Boston,
I had not started to shave.
Okay.
You know, you, you reach a certain age and you say, okay, now you shave.
I hadn't reached that when I got the Boston.
So I spent the first three or four bussets explaining why I had a beard
and why they should shave it off.
And the more they question, the more I dug in my heels.
You know,
because, uh,
go back to college
and the freshmen, they had to buy your pair of shoes.
And I bought a pair of white ones.
And the Boston coach says,
we wear black shoes.
That's the varsity.
This is the freshman team.
He says, you should get black shoes so you'll be like the rest of them.
I said, coach,
I had nothing.
I could ever do the literacy guys.
There were two black guys on the, on, on, on,
there were four black guys on varsity and the junior varsity on the freshman.
So there's no way I was going to look like a racial guy.
You know, and so,
one thing I got from my dad
was to analyze
and come conclusions from my own perspective.
See, I cannot tell you who your hero should be.
And you'd be wrong if you think you could tell me who my hero should be.
And Frank,
who was it all?
Bill Wamp,
who's your dear friend.
And I think a really good guy.
We're talking about growing up.
And then the conversation he said to me,
we come from two different worlds.
Really?
You know,
or friend of mine is a young guy named Y'all mate.
He plays, he's retired now.
He's playing for the Houston Rockets.
And he asked if he could have a conversation with me.
I said, okay.
So he came to my house for dinner here.
And we were talking about his career.
And I said, there's one thing you should be very aware of
and never lose sight of.
You are a very tall Chinese man.
Embrace it.
Uses are always embraced your mother and father.
And the culture you grew up in.
And I said, always be true to who you are and which you are.
And that to me is a positive thing, not a negative thing.
Because I can, you can be Chinese and love the Chinese
without hating the Americans,
which some people will try to conclude.
And you can embrace who you are and what you are.
And be a positive impact in your life.
Let's pause with this.
Okay.
Okay, we're rolling.
Ready to go.
All right.
We want to resume talking a little bit about your relationship
with the city of Boston and how it changed from the time
of the day to the day when you've made peace to some degree
with certain people there.
That never happened.
It never happened.
See, we're all the people that I was bothered.
But I was never bothered.
I think I'm about to mention about certain things.
But I always was able to maintain control.
Just like one thing that I know the media there was.
They turned the head and looked up and I was gone.
You know, it just...
I told Red to unpelished that I'm not going to do it anymore.
He told me what I told.
You know, they were misconcephalists.
The things that they valued and things that they were different.
I told someone last month, I never ever needed to be bothered
at all.
You know, I came.
I did what I did.
Even I left.
I just like I told those guys on NBA TV.
They said, how come they never pick you as a greatest player
in the game?
I said, first of all, that's irrelevant.
And I don't even get into that.
Because nobody can know who the best player was.
Because there is not an accepted standard.
That this is what the great player does.
And now, spectators are the only real experts.
Like I want to tell you a story if you got time.
I was working for CBS.
And there was a game.
The makers played the Sixers in Philadelphia.
And the Atlantic had to play center because the Korean was home
with a migraine.
And we were in production meeting.
And the announcer, who would go out and ate.
So I said, we're going to have to start promoting it to the Sixers game.
If the Lakers won, it was over.
If the Sixers won, it had to go to the Seven Game.
And the NASA kept saying, well, we're going to have to start promoting the Seven Game
a little later than the end of the first quarter.
So after the third time, he said that.
He said, I said, why are you saying that?
He said, without Korean, the Lakers can't compete.
And then the game would be over the first eight minutes.
I said, the Lakers are going to win the game.
And you know what he said to me?
You do not know what you're talking about.
The normal answer to this slide.
But that time, I just didn't feel like reading this slide.
I said, yes, I do.
I said, I know more about the play of basketball than anybody you ever meet.
He said, well, how can you say that?
I said, there are certain criteria you use in play-offs.
First, there's matchups.
You take magic on the back court and you're left with Norm Nixon and Michael Cooper,
open guest Andrew Tony and Maurice Cheeks.
I said, where did you get your watch?
No one has the advantage.
I said, where did you get my old Wix's play?
He in the dock?
That's a watch.
The other four are Andrew Jim Jones and either Colwell Jones or Chuck and Thunder.
You're rolling.
Okay.
So you said that those were a watch and...
And I've been on Dawkins or Colwell Jones and...
Of the six or...
Jim Jones.
There will be a six or a bad-ish.
I said, but the guy that's left is completely out of it.
He's got to try and guard magic.
Magic is big and strong enough to guard him, but he can't even catch up with magic.
In fact, magic, I, some of us, was the top three fastest guys in the league in footspeed.
So this guy, Magic, playing at the center, he can't...
He never see magic in fact.
I said, so, ah, okay, that's just matchups.
This will be the sixth straight game that the Lakers have played this six or a team.
During the way they get to the sixth game, they made adjustments, made adjustments.
So they're familiar.
Okay.
Now, this is the first game that the sixers will have played this Laker team with Magic at center.
As great as Kareem Meos, you always know where to find them.
He's down on the blocks, either left or right side.
Magic, he might be selling popcorn.
You know, he can be all over the building.
Okay.
So now, the sixers are going to have to make adjustments as they go along tonight.
By the time they make adjustments to this team, you'll be late in training camp next season.
I said, so, ah, if the sixers were to play, the best game,
that any team in his franchise that ever played, they would still lose.
They do not have a chance.
Wow. Did you say that on the air, too?
No, I said that in production, me.
Right, right.
And so, ah, we're going there and exactly what I told you would happen, happened.
The ball looks got 35 points.
Magic was uncontrollable.
The back corner was washed.
In fact, a kid named Brent Holley came off the bench and got 10 points.
And so, ah, the sixers never had a chance.
Oh, they were a good team.
Ah, they basically went to the six game on arm.
Yeah.
You know, and so, these are kind of things you have to know to where to play off.
Because every game is different.
Let's go back.
If the coach is any good, it's okay.
Let's go back to where we were talking a little bit before about your famous autograph policy.
He surprised me.
I didn't know this by saying that it didn't have it when you first started with the Celtics.
But it came about almost by accident a few years later over signing basketball.
In 1964.
This would have finally made decision.
I'm not going to do that anymore.
And you said it had to do with signing basketballs?
Well, that's where it started.
Well, ah, and by this time, I started to get
a bit cranky.
Okay.
And,
until, often, best ball court,
nobody could tell me what to do.
Okay.
That's a deal.
We can yell at her if you want to.
I spent from that time in 1964.
I think it stopped until today.
You'd be surprised that people try to figure a way to make me sign on the grass.
You know, and when I first took this coach and jargon, Boston,
they asked me to do a red, ask me to do a couple of TV shows.
And I said, well, I'm going to have to start signing on the grass.
I said, no, I'm not.
He had a red card and told you that you have to start signing on the grass.
Of course, you're part of management.
I said, first of all, red knew what I was before you off of me to job.
I didn't just say, okay, now that I'm on the coach, I'm not going to start on the grass.
That's been my policy for years at the time.
And I said, people keep asking me about that.
And I won't tell you one thing, okay?
If I say to you, I'm not going to start on the grass.
That's the end of it.
There's nobody you could tell that's okay, you start on the grass.
I said, if all my gods said to me, you start on the grass, and I said, no.
Even he cannot make me start on the grass if it's a he.
He could strike me dead.
But one thing that God gave us all is a free will.
And so, if I say I'm not going to do it, there's no point talking about it.
That's not going to happen.
Didn't you say that some of the Celtics, uh, uh, take your signature on basketball, though?
Oh, yeah.
Hanson Ramsey South.
I think sometime Casey.
They used to have a car just to do the best bill, Russell's.
So there are a lot of counterfeit Russell autographs out there on basketball.
Oh, yeah.
Well, I can remember in the 70s, being out at, um, restaurants with you,
when people would come up right in restaurants and walk right up and ask you to sign an autograph.
And my memory is that you would say, because usually they would have their kids there,
you would say, if you want to sit down and say hello and have a conversation, that's fine.
But I'm not going to sign an autograph.
No, I said, uh, what do kids want to have asked me about sign autographs?
I said, to me, to you, you're not personal.
It's a matter of policy.
I said, I don't sign autographs.
That goes to everybody, not just you, you know, and, uh, I have a choice.
I make a choice.
And so, uh, most of the kids understand that one of the things I used to always joke about,
I got to say, I want you sign an autograph, I sign autographs autographs.
You said, for my kid, I said, that's a bad trade.
And that's a bad trade.
Am I right in remembering that when you were asked about playing for boss and you would say,
you never played for boss and you played for the cell.
That's right. I played for Celtics.
For the team.
Yeah.
Well, you know, after I retired, I moved to LA right away.
I was sitting and taking hold of for four years for Los Angeles Lakers.
And, uh, they had a ceremony for Jerry West.
And they said, uh, would you come to, of course, I like Jerry a lot.
So, while I was there, they put me in a box next to Jack and Cook, who owned the team.
That was an experience.
Anyway, a couple of days later, I get a call from Jack and Cook.
He says, uh, I've been thinking about it and I made a decision.
I'm going to get you to come on retirement and play for the Lakers.
So, I said, aren't you playing a guy named Wilson with a lot of money?
To play for the Lakers?
Now, how do you feel about being a backup center?
Jack and Cook didn't think that was funny.
So, I said, no, no.
I don't play basketball anymore.
And if I did, it was only big for the Celtics.
That's the other time I would play basketball.
Could you talk a little bit about your relationship with the Red Sox over the issue of throwing out the first ball and your mentoring foundation and how that developed at Indie River retirement recently?
Well, when I was a Japanese of the Mayor of Boston asked me to come back to the Democratic National Convention and co-host his receptions.
And he had other receptions in community centers all around Boston.
And so, while I was there, my agent at the time had set up for me to go out.
And the last series of years were the Red Sox and the Yankees.
And so that's a big deal in Boston.
So, he had set up for me to go out and throw out the first pitch.
And so, he says, we got to be on the fedway by 11.
I said, I'm not going to the fedway point.
He says, why not? I said, because I'm not.
I'm not doing the Red Sox.
He says, well, I'm already set up.
I said, well, you have to answer it, because I'm not going to do it.
I'm not going to have nothing to do with the Red Sox.
As far as I'm concerned, the Red Sox can burn in hell for eternity.
And why was that?
Well, when I was with the Celtics, the guy that owns Red Sox said he would never have a black player.
In fact, they were less amazing to get a black player.
They do not owe me or any other black person anything.
That's their business and the way they want to run it.
That does not mean I have to so shame with them.
So, I was at a reception at some lady walked up, said, she's working with Red Sox.
I said, okay, she said, well, why don't you come on and throw the first piece?
I said, I'm not having nothing to do with the Red Sox.
She said, well, the Red Sox has changed.
This is different.
I said, well, you show me that you have a program to facilitate the change.
Maybe we'll talk.
That doesn't mean I'm comfortable with it.
I said, you're not going to keep the same policy.
It give Bill Russell come through at the first pitch.
And, say, see, we've changed.
That's not just not going to happen.
So, fast forward, I have a charity that I've been working with for almost 20 years.
It's called Mentoring.
And we have so far a very successful program.
We started out with a name one to one, one mentor, one mentor.
Last year, 2012, we passed eight million volunteers to our country.
Four million, I'm sorry.
Four million volunteers throughout the country that are one to one mentoring.
But it's not just black kids.
It's kids.
In the Boston chapter, we've got a lot of Hispanic kids.
Loss of Hispanic kids.
Loss of black kids.
A lot of white kids.
The only requirement is you be a kid.
And someone who spent some time helping you get started.
And we have found that this adult's that volunteered to be mentors end up profiting more than the kids.
Because you find out on a very personal basis how you can be helpful.
So, you asked the Red Sox to become active?
Well, I asked Red Sox. They had three or four owners.
I said, I want one of those owners to go on the board of my charity.
Not to say we support it. Go on the board.
They said, well, don't you want to play? I said, no, I don't want to play.
There's nothing I don't restrict to players or not.
But the owners can make policy decisions.
And the owners are not likely to get trained in the way.
So, they're players or the Red Sox.
As far as I'm talking, nice, nice, much of young guys who are prone to be active in the community.
And so, I said, but it's not insulting. It's not important.
I want somebody from Red Sox that can make decisions and policy.
So, we got one of the owners to go on the board.
And he's done an absolutely marvelous job.
In fact, most of the people are doing them think that mentoring is a Red Sox program.
I can live with that.
Because that's the biggest voice in doing it. It's a Red Sox.
And they were all out.
That's your fault.
We're going.
So, the Red Sox stepped up to meet your conditions and support the mentoring.
Yes. What they did was they got twice a year at Fenway Park.
They have stepped up to play for mentoring.
And on the green monster, they have a better.
They listed number of people they brought into the mentoring program.
And for every Red Sox game, there are four seats set aside for two mentors and two mentees
that have been together for three years or more.
They're the guests in the Red Sox.
And they've encouraged their sponsors.
And they're all...
Well, anyway, they encourage people to do business with them to start mentoring programs and their companies.
So, they've been really super.
So, when did somebody from the Red Sox call you up and say,
we think we've met your conditions.
We've tried to make a change. Are you ready to throw out the first ball?
I did.
I didn't get it over the plate though.
Wow. How long ago was that that you threw out the first pitch?
Well, it must have been... maybe six years ago.
So, after they won the World Series?
Yes.
Because my late wife and I were back there a couple times.
And Red Sox did some very nice.
They started scholarship for one of the city kids in Boston.
And named it a male or not, Russell scholarship.
And...
And named it from Aaron.
Yes.
And I didn't really please me a lot because that was my good friend.
And so, then how long after that was it to the city of Boston?
Was it the mayor who approached you about the statue?
Yeah, well, after I got to the Medal of Freedom,
and Obama says, somebody there will be a statue of Boston from Bill Russell.
And I told him I never put a giving for that.
Because when Tom...
Oh, man, they don't want to tell me about the statue.
I said, you know, it sounds a me a lot like a tombstone.
And he says, why don't you say that?
I said, well, you know,
if you really, truly believe in God,
he does not need a marker to find you.
So I said, I would be willing to be buried in an unmarked grave.
But, of course, if you really believe in God,
he doesn't need a marker to find you.
He was exactly where you are.
And so, what Tom says, well, I said, besides that,
I don't need anything like that.
He says, well, it's not so much for you, it is for the city.
You've made our tremendous amount of difference in community and racial relations.
Of course, my way of thinking,
I've not got past the place where we were beyond race.
Even I had dead dome.
But, that can be, if you wanted to be,
a healthy part of community relations,
that's the answer difference.
When they found out that, when I made decisions,
it was based on competence, not on race.
And that's all they didn't want to ask them anybody,
is that, oh, if you're going to make a decision
and race becomes a part of your decision-making process,
which you have to really go to is competence.
And, like I always say, long ago,
so that's me, what would I think about a gay person planning MBA?
This was years and years and years ago.
And I said, have one question.
What would you like to do if you could get a job?
I don't know.
If we do this, we're going to have you make all the key decisions.
And, first, I looked at five different sites in Boston,
with the city manager, to see where we're going to put it.
And we ended up at City Hall Plaza,
which is adjacent to the Freedom Trail
and near the old state house.
And we're going to put a little bit of an alley,
but it's going to be like the Valley of Champions.
And so for all the teams at the White Championship,
both have a star.
Lead up to the statue.
And it will have some of my pet phrases like,
they're those such things as other people's kids.
They're all next generation Americans.
And a few things like that.
On the statue.
Knowing the little plaques all around.
So, but Tom did not have me convinced yet.
And so, he says, okay, we're going to set up a legacy foundation
to support mentoring.
And so every year we'll have fun races around the statue
to raise money for mentoring.
And that's a good way to get real personal community involvement
in the educational system.
And when you get that,
you see like I saw a thing on TV the other day
that in terms of literacy and all that kind of stuff,
America's in the second 10.
Well, how are you going to maintain a viable
part of the future?
If you don't educate the next generation.
And the only way you can beat that is start a war.
Right.
And so, I don't think wars are helpful.
You mentioned getting the medal of freedom from President Obama.
What was that experience like?
I understand that he was a great athlete.
I think he's an extraordinary nice man, first of all,
and a good person.
But they asked me is that the highest I've ever got.
And I said just second.
And I said second, yeah.
Second?
Yeah.
Well, if that's second, what was the highest honor?
Well, when he was 75, my father said to me one day,
you know, I'm very proud of you.
That's my son.
I'm also proud that I'm your father.
And this is my hero.
And you can't talk to that.
You're not coming from the hero.
But it was a good second, right?
Oh, yeah, it was a good strong second.
What did he say about you're helping him become President?
He just said that it was a guy like me that made it possible
for him to be President.
I don't see that, but thanks anyway.
I really like him on a personal basis.
The first time I met him, we were dedicating the start of the work
on the monitor king, the monitor, and Washington.
And so he was with me.
I know you care and Russell's dead.
And you were the same thing Bill Clinton said to the first time I met him.
You know, and so this feels fun to be a parent and have so much to that.
I said, what about Chuck Limbaugh?
You also mentioned speaking of mentors and role models
that you were the only basketball pole bearer for Jackie Robinson.
Is that right? How did that come about?
All in none teammate.
The only non-brooklandager teammate.
Right.
Well, when Jackie started with the Dodgers, I was 13.
And he was the essence of an athletic hero.
He was the main player of the football team.
At the time of a children, there was nobody like that.
There were many guys that had no money, but they were not stand-up guys.
And so when Jackie died, Rachel Robinson called me and said,
I want you to be a pole bearer at Jackie's Field Room.
Well, that's right up there with a close number three.
Okay.
And so I said, of course, just tell me when it were.
I'm not a lot of kids from the projects in West Oakland.
I get to be a pole bearer for Jackie Robinson.
And so I said, why me?
She said, you were Jackie's favorite athlete.
Well, as far as fans and all that kind of stuff,
nobody else comes close to that.
You know, Jackie was our guy as a kid.
I was saying that he turned around and respected me.
And I took the attitude because of that.
What I thought about it, I said, Jackie took us for a four day to point B.
First black guy in the Asian League sports baseball.
Well, what I got with the Celtics,
I did not want to revisit that point A to point B.
I want to go point B to point C.
That's why I was kind of happy with the point that I coach.
And look at how important it is that you're the first black coach.
I say it's not important.
First of all, I'm the best person for this particular job.
And I know that.
And second, it'll be important.
The coaches are hired and fired with no reference to race.
Then it's important.
So like now coaches are and managers are fired wholesale.
Okay.
And nowadays, never is there reference to race.
We should speak just a little bit here toward the end because we mentioned Jackie as a role model.
And about your relationship with some, we've talked about your teammates,
but you also had some pretty celebrated rivals that you said your reaction with your relations with your adversaries
were special because they made you play better.
Well, that was it.
And Wilton and Elgin Baylor.
Not only that, but at that time with the NBA,
I was really seriously wished that every player in NBA could find a position where he could play his best.
Because then the people with the NBA games would see the best players in the world playing their best.
I kicked the ass at their best.
But that in a way, didn't that indirectly lead to your part of your feud?
I guess it's not quite the right word with Wilton because he didn't play in your last game
and you wanted him to make you earn it that last championship.
Well, no, you know, I talked to Wilton about that.
And I looked him to eye and I said, Wilton, I apologize for the stuff I said.
That was just humorous.
You know, it was my last game, not new it.
And nothing more than anything to make it less pleasant to me.
And I said things about him that I should not have said was I was speaking to a college group in Iowa, I think.
And there was a reporter in there mixed in with the kids.
I had a noise reporter.
And so we do this question actually.
He said, well, you never want that last championship in Wilton got hurt.
Well, it annoyed me.
Of course, in Wilton after game, we were 17 points ahead.
You know, and I went off on the Wilton and he had nothing to do with it.
And so I looked him and I and apologized to him and said it was just humorous.
I was not on that.
I was wrong.
But you did want him to be in the game because...
Yeah, because...
Something out of the competition.
Well, no, also, it was easy game.
We said deep voice ahead.
I don't want to change that.
You said once in one of your books here about Dr. King, I don't want...
I had the same reservation about Dr. King that I had about the Vietnam War,
which is that the white people in Boston liked him.
So I knew something must be wrong.
I guess that's a light moment.
Because there was a time when they were kind of superficial about race relations.
Yeah, well, the reason I was there that was also in Boston at the time
was the guy named Detroit Red.
I think it was Detroit Red, who later became Malcolm X.
And they were love to put them in opposites.
And through the choose the doctor, wasn't these people choosing...
I'm going to be suspicious.
Well, you know, when I always thought that...
Well, because I thought this way, it was a major problem,
but there was not one real solution.
And those very jars, they're snake, insulating, C.P.,
about five, six organizations find the same battle, but they were different approaches.
And I thought it was important that they all be able to maintain.
You see, because you get to a place where one organization speaks for a whole race.
The race is in trouble, because this one that I figured out had to beat that.
You know, let's let go.
I had a conversation with Nelson Mandela, and I told him how respectful I was of what he did.
And what I think he did not do, he did not disembowel violence.
Now, he was not going to advocate a civil war, but he said that if he'd say he turns his back on violence,
all of his comrades trying to change their part time, they would put a target on their back.
And so he wouldn't do that.
So that there were probably a dozen or more groups in South Africa fighting a part time.
Each was an older agenda, and they're on style of paying the same problem.
And so I've never put down any of those groups trying to change things.
Let me ask you three sum up questions to Ann.
First of all, be looking back on your career in your life.
Do you have any major regrets as to things that you would have done differently?
What's that?
Do you have anything, any major regrets that you would have liked to have done differently?
I don't know.
For the South Africa, I was opposed to racism being part of the atmosphere.
And I did, when I thought I could do, to help change it, or at least expose it.
Expose it as a good first step.
Yes.
You could ever help to solve a problem until you recognize it as a problem.
So I don't know.
See, I was not your intellectual.
I don't know if it's like I could do to change it.
And how do you look at today's NBA?
Because you're a part of it again.
They've got the award name for you.
You go to the final, compared to your NBA.
Do you think the future of the league is still good?
Well, you know, I was watching the playoffs the other day.
I was watching a lot of good players, a lot of them.
Like what I was planning, maybe four guys are making two, three-poort shots.
And they're every team's got four guys, because you're three-poort shots.
The game has changed though.
It's evolving of all the games.
And so I always say that I would never ask a player to play against ghost, past, present, or future.
You know, how do you do that, and so on?
So, well, that's a different time.
You don't like that?
Well, guys, be one time.
How'd you've done a good shot?
I said, first of all, you got to question backwards.
And I love the kid.
I really do.
I said, but you can't compare players with different errors.
Because, for example, for all intensive purposes, I invented the block shot.
Okay.
I'd never seen a shot block to domestic or do it.
Which act was four, five years old, block shots were integral part of the game.
So he starts at five, where I started at 18.
Well, you can't never compare that.
You know what I mean?
And there are certain standards.
For example, when I was playing, there was no such thing as a zone defense allowed.
We were not allowed to play so.
Now, everybody played zones.
There were variations only between their zones.
And we had contempt for teams that played zones.
Because they had at least one or two guys that couldn't play defense.
And so the zone protected them.
Well, now the zone's integrated part of it.
And if it's playing right, it can be very effective.
So finally, this interview will become part of the archives of the new National Museum of African American History.
Taylor, you go put me an archive?
I'm going to put you in there.
Who are you?
You're Indiana Jones?
Well, you're going to be looking out to an awful lot of people.
Do you have any advice for young people that are going to come to this museum as to how they should go about,
and print them in their choices for their life?
Well, if you're fortunate to find something you do well,
approach it professionally.
Finally, what's all about?
And how can you take what's all about
and make an improvement from your point of view?
And you take things from a novelty to a professional.
You know, things that you enjoy doing well.
Well, now when I was an activist playing basketball,
first let me get that straight.
We should be, we should travel before the jet fleets.
Or if it's foggy, you just stay there.
And so you might spend all day at the airport.
And every day at the airport one time I forget where.
And this guy walked me, you kind of told a very suit observation.
You're a basketball player?
I said no.
So about five or six guys came up and asked the same question.
You're a basketball player?
I said no.
So have a check with them once in a while, and he said to me,
how come you say you're not a basketball player?
I said, John, that's what I do, that's not what I am.
I'm a man that works at professional basketball.
See, the Miss Nomer is there, and everybody says play.
Where you long since finished playing.
You know, and if you don't know,
the closest we came to play was in Celtics, we had a motto.
Playing like children with our big childish.
Is that your motto?
Well, it was just in the air around there.
I don't know who, but we took it.
And the way we won all those championships
was we knew how to play.
Now, this sounds odd, everybody knows how to play.
Everybody does not have the total team concept.
When I was in my best with the Celtics,
I could run all my plays from all five positions.
Point guard, shooting guard, small forward, big forward, post.
I could run the plays from all those positions.
Not that I wanted to run the plays.
But if what about friends was having a problem, I could understand that.
And know how to help.
And you know, where help comes from and how it comes.
So finally, have you been back to Monroe any time?
You talked about your mother and...
No.
If I go there to be on a duress.
No, it's like this, Taylor.
I started my life in Monroe.
And the white people in Monroe were really mean to me and my family.
It's told my grandfather.
I mean, not just Will, but they were actually mean.
Like the one time he's on the sheriff or deputy sheriff.
And my mother very proudly bought her a riding habit, you know, the little jacket and the pants with the flare and the boots.
And the sheriff walks up to her and says, you get off the street with those outfits on.
You can't dress like no one.
What's wrong with you?
If I ever see you like that again, I'm going to put you under the jail.
And the sheriff's so bad, she probably shook for two or three days.
Well, I don't feel like...
Well, I go back to my old hometown.
No, that did not make sense to me.
And so, I don't go to one room.
There's less to the after my mother died.
I took my boys there once and I think it's all until I've been there.
You thought you might go visit her grave sometime?
Didn't you say you might go visit her grave sometime?
Yeah, you know what?
I would not know how to fight.
Well, she gave you an awful good start.
Yes, she did, and I really appreciate it.
But I just don't get to that part of the country anymore.
All right, I think we're done.
You guys have any other questions?
I think we're good, Bill.
Thanks a lot.
That's all right, John.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.